And available right now. Everlast
Whitey Ford House of Payne. You.
Yes sir. How are you sir? How are
you doing man? See your brothers.
Because the minute you going to Vegas
this weekend for the fights. Yeah man,
we got a little party the night before.
We were doing a little show
at the Brooklyn Bowl with
my buddy evidence and cell
phones. You don't, the way
I would put the headphones,
I feel like I'm alone here with the
headphones on it. There we go. Here we go.
Now we're on the same team. Now
we're locked in. Um, does this out?
This is out right? Yeah, it came out about
three weeks ago, something like that.
Maybe a month. Beautiful. I've been
in Europe for the home. Lunch is torn.
So this is like everything Everlast
presents Whitey Ford's house of pain.
Yeah. It's, it's, you know,
it's everything in the toolbox
I brought to this record.
So that's Kinda where the title
came from. Just, you know,
it's been eight years since
my last real studio album, so
I figured, hey, maybe this
could be the last one. I hope
not. Buttons, just like I,
you know, I mean like, you know, that my
story is like, you know, with the family,
I dedicate a lot more of my time to the
family than I used, you know? Yeah. Um,
just cause of some of the, you
know, um, extra issues we deal with,
which everything is wonderful and
great. Now, you know, and dude,
I'm 30 pounds lighter than the
last time I was here. I honestly,
it started here because I put,
I purposely came here that day.
It was the first time, if you remember,
it just, it was wild garden and gun,
a thousand podcasts
since that day. But, uh,
it was the first time I had come out
and they started talking about anything
like, you know, that was going on in my
life in a public way. And uh, you know,
and I,
I got a lot off my chest that day and I
also planned that day to put myself in a
position to hold myself
accountable by this, by stating I,
I don't feel good about
the way I look right now.
And I reached out for like,
theoretically for help, you know,
and I got an incredible response from
the podcast audience and my own fans.
I mean, I got offered from
everybody everywhere how to do this,
that and the other. Um, didn't really
need that because within my own circle,
some people stepped up and I also did it
to hold myself accountable to put it in
the universe. Like I've thrown
it out there now. Like I,
I put it up there on the wall
and, and, and stamped it and said,
here's what I want out of life right now.
And you know,
there's nobody stopping me but me and at
sometimes some of the things I used to,
I used to get on and see
you talking about the,
I'm not letting this inner
bitch kicked my ass today.
And I just started taking things like
that to heart, you know? And again,
after you change,
what did you do different that we started
talking about it last time. Therapy,
you know what I mean has helped a lot for
me because of this, you know, the, the,
the added pressures are family faces.
With my oldest daughter having
cystic fibrosis, you know,
it just for a long time it
was just learning how to
live life with it, you know?
And that got heavy. There was some
real dark heavy moments, you know,
scary moments for her in the
hospital. You know, so we,
I mean as a human or you know,
you have this baby and you're just trying
to figure out how to not screw it up
with a normal health situation,
you know, this is this thing.
So it took a long time for me to come
to terms. At first I got really angry,
I got into some real, you know,
Lieutenant Dan war with God kind of stuff,
you know, at the top of the
sail boat flip, you know,
as I was there all the way.
And it got to a point where I almost,
I was that I almost got locked up for
trying to fight a cop that was, you know,
trying to just talk to me about something,
you know, and I just lost. I was,
I had no,
I had so much anger over so
much that I wasn't dealing with.
And then I found a guy that just
really got me therapists and, and it,
it began the, the, the, the ball
rolling of understanding how to,
how to cope with a lot of that stuff,
you know? Wow. So, um, as far as like,
first of all, you look really good.
They thanks, your face looks great,
your skin looks good. I'm taking a lot
better care of myself. It looks like it.
Thank you. What are you doing different
as far as like how you eat or,
I'm just eating cleaner, you know,
and just trying not to, you know, uh,
to be more aware of what's in the food
and listening to meet and stuff. You know,
I'm still part of the whole commercial
meat system though. I long to, to,
to get it to a situation where I'm hunting
and doing things like that. It's just,
we had talked about that for a while.
You want her to try hunting pigs to hone.
Right. I asked you what would be the
best starting point and you were like,
you know, they got bore up there.
Well to hone and I know some guys and,
and I actually contacted them and I, you
know, I just, again, this light so busy,
it's not just this, it's the, it's
the added stress of like, you know,
I have a wife that when I go on the road,
she's the sole handled her of these
problems. You know what I mean?
And so that these things, you know,
pile on you guilt and this, you know,
stress and all this, you
know? Yeah. And, um, so yeah,
it's just between that and when I'm home,
I just invest myself. I want to be home.
I want to do as much as I
can to lift that weight.
So like I get caught up by the things,
all the things I want to do,
I can't do all the time, you know
what I mean? But it started again.
Now I'm taking care of myself.
Like I'm actually just about to start
Jujitsu again, you know, which I'm, yeah.
Because I forever,
I was so goddamn fat in the middle of the
hip escapes where like, you know, every,
I was hurting my back or my neck.
Every other time I tried to do,
I just quit because it was
getting, you know, I mean,
I mean I wasn't super advanced.
I was probably pretty close to
getting a blue belt. You know,
I was about a year in, on like four
lessons a week with just the private,
I was with mark as Vanessa said,
Beverly Hills Jujitsu for awhile.
So now I'm just looking to see
what I want to do. You know,
I've talked to Eddie a few times,
I'm talking to a few other guys.
Cron has thrown my way.
Doing any exercise at
all besides that cardio,
not much weights or anything like that.
Just, you know, keeping it moving.
I two hours, two hours
on stage tonight. Right.
It's good to do something first.
Uh,
I feel like I always
tell people like Jujitsu,
so grueling that I think a why,
I mean you could just jump in and you
will get in shape through Jujitsu,
but a good thing to do is like find a
place that teaches you kettlebells and
take some kettlebell classes and just,
just get your body strong
enough that it can.
I remember one of the things Marcus
used to do brought Marcus used to run me
around the gym for 30 minutes
before we could even start a lesson.
Like I literally had to Puke
for the first like month. Yeah.
That's that old school way a lot.
And then it would take so long
that he would be like, all right,
you're past the puke and thing you
ran and what I mean, but it was like,
at first I would like literally
be run till I was puke.
And then the crazy part about it is this
15 minutes after you felt great when
you were doing the last thing. So
it was, and I'll work. Yeah, those,
there's the old school guys, that's how
they used to do it. They used to, um,
like all the old school
Carlson Gracie classes,
you'd have a grueling physical workout,
first hip escape, push ups, sit ups,
body weight squats,
all this different stuff.
There's a good thought process behind
that. Not just that it gets you in shape,
but also that you learn how to do Jiu
Jitsu when you're tired so that you learn
how to just use technique and
not use like physical strength.
You're almost having no choice
but to relax. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a people that
disagree with that though.
They think you learn technique when
you're fresh in it, like sits and better,
but it's just two different
schools of thought, you know?
I don't think he either.
One is right.
It's definitely good to understand
what it's like to be tired and how to,
how to train and how to, how to push
yourself when you're tired. Sure. Yeah.
I'm excited.
I'm really looking forward to it.
Like I just started talking about
it like about two weeks ago.
Really getting back, well, that's
a lot of weight to lose, man.
That's a big accomplishment. I've got
15 to go to really to hit my goal. Yeah.
Hold it be to 25 to 25.
Good weight. Yeah. Um,
are you taking vitamins or supplements
or anything along those lines?
Like a daily, um, but I, you know,
I have restrictions because I take blood
thinners and stuff cause it's titanium
heart valve I have,
I have to have a vitamin that's devoid
of a vitamin K because that's what makes
your blood clot.
So I like a lot of things like a lot of
the juicing things and like things like
that.
When you want to go on a juice cleanse,
I can't do it cause it's like a lot of
it's Kale based and like Kale is a heavy
green.
Whether it's high in vitamin K it'll
totally like screw up my blood chemistry,
you know, cause I'm going
the other direction with
blood thinners. Jesus Christ,
I have to otherwise like a clock could
hit like stick to that titanium valve,
break off and wind up in my brain,
you know what I mean?
And then Tom stroked out and that's
the last thing we need. Fuck yeah.
I remember when you put the microphone
up to your heart and you can hear that.
Yeah.
I would say I'm so,
so like when I'm in here I've keep
feeling like you can hear it anyway.
It's like all through this, I hear
it. 20 this white noise to me,
if I want to hear it,
I can hear,
I can take my pulse like this just
by telling you, wow. Two, three.
You could feel it.
I can hear it in my own skull.
Like I could hear it in my
bones, I can hear it. It's in me.
How long is that good for ever? Forever.
Forever. As long as I take care of him.
I was, I mean it's been
20 years. Literally in,
in 2018 it happened. 90 or [inaudible]
98. Wow. And, um, I just get, you know,
as long as I keep the thin, the blood
thinners going and, and you know,
that get checked in, you know, two
times, three times a year, you know,
and then the blood thinners it because
if you got a clot it would somehow or
another get stuck in that val
clock could like, or, or you know,
it's a titanium valves, the clock could
actually form on it that the metal,
like it could the book, if
it's the blood's too sticky
into co has too much clod,
he could stick to the bow then break off
and then wind up in your brain. Whoa.
You know? So what does do avoid
blood clots in general? Yeah.
What's the difference between
that and the RECO regular valve?
What would happen with a regular oven?
The other choice would have been a pig
valve and those are good for about 15
years. Like they usually open
you up again? Yeah, I would
have had to have it done.
I'd probably be do. Yeah. I probably right
now too, like I'd be like, go here I go.
Yeah. Yeah. They do that for older people
is what they do. Could like, you know,
when you get into your sixties they,
you know,
really explore that because they don't
think you're going to be around 50 more
rice, you know, they just say,
well here, just for now. Yeah,
so it was called a saint Jude's
St Jude's artificial valve.
Powerful medical technology. Eddie Bravo
has got a titanium disk in his back now.
Yeah. He just had a surgery this right?
Yeah. His back moves around. Great.
It like he was fully compressed
whether it was like nothing left.
It was basically bone on bone.
He was in pain all the time and they just
opened them up and put a fake valve in
there. That's crazy. Were
fake desk rather in there,
but it's articulating so like moves
around like a regular desk. Like he's his,
it doesn't, it's not like he's fused.
Even if you're seeing people that are off.
I have a friend that got that
down. Yeah, they're super stiff.
Like wherever it is is basically locked
down. There's no movement to it anymore,
but Eddie's is actually,
it moves like a real disk.
It shit that's going to be coming down
the pipeline. It's going to be crazy, man.
Yeah. I mean, I know people
with fake everything.
I know people with fake hips and fake
knees and what's fake? Heart valves.
Heart valves. Yeah. Yeah.
It's amazing. I mean.